NO, I don’t think we can talk about the
Caribbean without mentioning the Dominican
Republic.
It’s major tourist destination with the
largest economy and even the highest mountain
of all the island countries in the Caribbean.
The Dominican Republic is a very, very special
place in Latin America.
And I’m not only saying this because we
can find amazing places such as Punta Cana,
Bayahibe or Puerto Plata here, among many
others.
But also because this was the first place
where Christopher Columbus’s men settled
when America was discovered in 1492.
Yes, it’s true.
For good or ill, everything started here,
this is where Latin America, as we know it,
began.
Its capital, Santo Domingo was the first modern
city on the entire American continent.
Here the first cathedral, the first university
and the first hospital were built.
But... yes, it's true, if we associate the
Dominican Republic with anything, it's tourism.
(THE SUN REVOLUTION)
This is by far this country’s best face.
And not for nothing.
Folks, the Dominican Republic is trendy.
Thanks to its 1,000 miles of coastline, more
than 250 miles of amazing Caribbean beaches,
its golf courses and huge all-inclusive resorts,
the country is experiencing an impressive
tourist boom.
Of course... this story has been developing
for a while.
See, during the 40s, the then plenipotentiary
dictator of the island, General Rafael Trujillo
, gave the order to encourage tourism.
Probably, with the intention of filling up
his pockets.
That’s how the Malecón de Santo Domingo
and the first luxury hotel in the city, the
Hotel Jaragua, opened in 1944.
Years later, in 1968, the first legislation
that considered tourism development to be
of national interest was approved.
So as you can see, an emphasis on tourism
isn’t new here.
But...
In recent years, it has completely taken off.
In 2017, the Dominican Republic, a country
with just over 10 million inhabitants, managed
to attract more than 7 million tourists.
It grew so quickly that the country is expected
to overcome the 10 million international tourists
barrier in no more than 3 years.
And of course, as you can imagine all this
has consequences:
See, in the last 5 years direct foreign investment
in the tourism sector has grown by more than
500%, that is, it has multiplied by 6.
Nowadays, the Dominican Republic has more
than 80,000 hotel rooms... and this number
won’t stop growing.
(“To give you an idea, to accommodate all
these visitors, in 2017 Dominican hotels opened
8,366 new rooms and an additional 15,000 are
under construction.”
Danilo Medina, President of the Dominican
Republic.)
The result?
Tourism is already the island’s main economic
activity, and if we take both the wealth this
generates directly and indirectly into account...
it means 1 out of every 4 pesos generated
by the economy.
25%!
We could say that the Dominican Republic has
discovered and is beginning to exploit its
peculiar oil.
And the truth is that, in this area, almost
all news is good.
Check out one of their latest achievements...
which happened in exchange for breaking with
Taiwan.
("The People’s Republic of China is opening
up to Dominican tourism.
The Chinese authorities declare the Dominican
Republic as a tourist destination for its
citizens” El Día.)
Of course... just a moment… because that’s
not it.
Folks, the Dominican Republic has a different
face.
Because here, in this country, we can find
a lot of light, yes… but also a lot of the
shadows that we commonly see today in Latin
America.
Let’s take a look.
(THE OTHER FACE)
The Dominican Republic has achieved one of
the highest growth rates in Latin America
and the Caribbean in the last 25 years.
This strong performance has actually meant
achieving a higher purchasing power parity,
as well as one of the 10 highest per capita
incomes in all of Latin America.
At almost $17,000, the Dominican Republic
is paired with Costa Rica and well above countries
such as Peru, Colombia or Ecuador.
But wait a second because that’s not the
whole story.
In spite of everything, 32% of all Dominicans,
that is, one in three people, live below the
poverty line; the average life expectancy
barely exceeds 70 and infant mortality is
almost 5 times higher than in the developed
countries.
That may explain why we can find one and a
half million Dominicans in the United States...
and why after tourism, remittances are the
second largest source of wealth.
But... having said that, I think the question
we can all ask ourselves is, how can such
a paradise not take off?
Well folks… the answer is that this Caribbean
land has many of the "evils" that unfortunately
are all over Latin American.
Yes, the continent’s modern history began
here in 1492.
Now, 526 years later, we can find a good reflection
of the best and worst in Latin America in
this exact same place.
But... delving into the matter, the first
great point of darkness we can find is the
stubborn persistence in keeping policies that
have repeatedly been shown not to work--an
issue that seems to reign in this region.
For example, in matters of informal work--
irregular employment-- which is a serious
problem that has spread throughout the region.
See, the workers who are exposed to this situation,
to informality, work under more precarious
conditions, with greater instability, problems
obtaining financing – be it to buy a house,
invest in a business or to properly educate
their children – and of course lower wages.
Because… obviously… a company will invest
much less money in an employee who’s hired
irregularly.
And this is also a problem for the government,
for example, when it comes to collecting taxes.
Well, in the Dominican Republic, informal
employment affects 6 out of every 10 workers.
Because in this country, not only is that
number not decreasing, it’s growing.
In 2017, for example, formal jobs were only
created in the public sector.
And what does this info tell us?
Well, that formal hiring involves many barriers
and burdens: bureaucracy, taxes, outdated
regulations, that anyone setting up a business
has to pay taxes even before they make a single
dollar, etc, etc...
And all that, logically, makes it difficult
for private economies to create quality jobs...
So with this data in hand...
I think it would make sense to say… hey…
if we need to boost formal hiring, let’s
just change what isn’t working, right?
Well, no, it doesn’t work like that.
The same goes for commercial policy.
See in a country with a small local market,
as is, precisely, the Dominican Republic’s
case, the foreign sector is essential.
Obvious, right?
Well, in this country we can basically find
two different situations.
On one hand, there’s the free zones, where
the companies installed have favorable conditions,
both regulatory and fiscal, which they provide
in exchange for basically only working in
exports, while meeting certain criteria and
being approved by the government.
On the other hand, there are the more normal
companies... which are the vast majority.
Well, more than half of all exports come from
the free zones...
And, additionally, in recent years exports
from these places have grown an average of
more than 5% every year.
But exports from common Dominican companies...
Well... check out this chart.
So upon seeing this... the question I ask
myself is... if the free zones work…
Why not extend their benefits to the rest
of the country so that Dominican companies
can become more competitive?
Well, no, that won’t happen either.
And then... there’s the issue of deficit,
public spending and debt.... which in spite
of the great number of bad experiences, continues
to be a vice of many Latin American governors.
Here, the Dominican Republic isn’t the exception
either.
Since 1990, public spending in the Dominican
Republic has multiplied... listen up… by
18.
Here, public deficit is almost
a tradition.
Now, just a moment...
You may be wondering.. but…
Simon... we’re talking about a country that’s
coming out of poverty... there’s lots to
do… infrastructure needs to be created,
like ports, airports, roads, etc, etc... so
that the country can grow.
Well...
Do you know what type of expenditure grows
the most?
No, sorry, it isn’t public investment, it’s
current expenditure!
Which has multiplied by almost 30 since 1990.
And of course... expenses have to be paid…
partly with more taxes, which slows down the
creation of formal jobs and investment, and
partly with debt.
Check out what’s happening with the Dominican
debt... with debt and interests... because
of course... debt has interests.
Listen up.
Indeed.
Almost one in four euros that the government
spends goes towards interests....
It’s the third largest figure in all of
Latin America and it won’t stop growing.
What a crazy business!
Well, despite the tourism sector’s takeoff,
this constant stubbornness with policies that
don’t work explains why Dominicans have
so many problems and why there’s still so
much poverty in the country.
Check out how this country ranks in the Global
Competitiveness Index.
But...
What about politicians?
Are they involved in other things?
Listen up, because the shadows don’t end
here... there’s more.
(SUSPICIONS)
Folks, the Dominican Republic is a fantastic
country and it probably has a promising future...
And when it manages to take that big step…
it really will be like paradise...
Think about it: Good weather, good beaches
and money.
Who could resist?
However, today the Dominican Republic has
two other very important problems that may
be stopping the country from taking off: the
first one is corruption.
(“Dominican Republic, among the 50 most
corrupt countries, according to Transparency
International” DiarioLibre)
You heard that right… the Dominican Republic
is considered one of the most corrupt countries
in the world.
According to Transparency International's
ranking, only Venezuela, Haiti, Guatemala
and Nicaragua are in a worse situation in
Latin America.
Here, corruption at all levels is very common...
Suspects range from the current socialist
president, Danilo Medina, who is accused of
having financed his electoral campaign with
bribes, to the police itself.
In fact, it was in the Dominican Republic
that the construction company Odebrecht installed
its coordination center for the bribes it
paid internationally in exchange for contracts.
And of course... many of these bribes remained
there, almost 100 million dollars.
As far as we know, these were received by
politicians and officials in exchange for
concessions, work awards and public contracts.
But unfortunately, that’s not all, the other
problem, which is growing... is drug trafficking.
The Dominican Republic is considered one of
the most important bridge counties and narcotics
distribution centers by the United States.
( “Drug traffickers have a problem exporting
drugs from Venezuela.
There are few commercial flights, little container
shipping, no tourists and a collapsed fishing
sector.
But the Dominican Republic, 1,400 kilometers
away, has it all”.
InSight Crime)
In fact, according to the DEA and the European
intelligence services, nowadays the Dominican
Republic is one of the main transit countries
for narcotics that go to the United States
and the most frequent for cocaine shipments
going to Europe.
And obviously this is an important issue...
but we'll talk about that some other day.
In any case, my friends, let's be clear.
These are problems that, unfortunately, are
common in almost the entire region.
The Dominican Republic has achieved a lot
in recent decades, it’s a fantastic place
and its future is promising.
In this video we wanted to show you some of
the reasons why this country isn’t doing
as well as it should.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.